بحثا عن الامل يتمسك العم عرفان بالبقاء
هنا والامل حفيدتان لا تزالان تحت
الانقاضيف لقد انتشلوا ابني وولديه وننتظر
خبرا عن ابنتيه ليس بيدنا شيء سوى
الانتظار
العمل في الموقع يسير بتانن خشيه مزيد من
الانهيارات بين الحين والاخر يتقدم احد
افراد فرق البحث والانقاذ لتقديم معلومات
للعائله
يسرع العم احمد الخطى عله يحظى باي خبر عن
ابنه
مع ثلاثه من اطفالها علقون في الطابق
الثالث نشعر بالتوتر فمع مرور الوقت تصبح
عمليه الانقاذ معقده
هذا المبنى انهار في الزلزال الاول
لبنى دموعهن حينا
ويكتفين بالدعاء دوما ان لطفا بالمفقودين
انتشل اخي وابنه من تحت الانقاض ويبحثون
عن بناتها الثلاث
وفجاه يتوقف كل شيء
لا شيء سوى الصمت
هنا لم يصلوا الى نتيجه بعد لكن في موقع
قريب الوضع اكثر قسوه انتشال ضحيه جديده
يقدر عدد الضحايا في المدينه حتى الان
بنحو 170 والاعداد مرشحه للارتفاع انهار
اكثر من 300 مبنى سكني وتجاري بشكل كامل
في مالاتيا تتشابه مشاهد الدمار في المدن
المنكوبه وحيث ما وليت وجهك تقابلك قصص
تفيض الما وحزنا قصص تختلف في تفاصيلها
لكن المشترك بينها
هو التعلق بامل
محاصر تحت الانقاض سلام خضر الجزيره
ملاطيا جنوب تركيا